[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
how much time will derek showman spend
behind bars for the murder of george
floyd his defense
is asking for time served and
prosecutors want 30 years
opening statements in the tennessee
trial of a father accused of murdering
his son
and disposing of his body did joseph
daniels beat his five-year-old to death
the defendant you will see has many
faces and
a first look into the new movie and
documentary on the case of missing mom
jennifer doulos this mom of five
is just suddenly gone plus heated
courtroom arguments in the murder trial
of robert durst
why the defense for the millionaire real
estate air are taking aim at the
prosecution
and judge i'm angry right now law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
derek showman is hoping for some
leniency when he is sentenced for the
murder of george floyd later this month
angela libya is here with what the
former police officer is asking
angenette yeah brian
derrick chovin's attorney eric nelson
filed this document in it he is asking
for a lighter prison term or even
probation and time served but
prosecutors
want a longer prison sentence
we the jury in the above entitled matter
find the defendant guilty
with derrick chauvin being found guilty
on all counts including second-degree
murder
prosecutors filed a document asking
judge cahill to sentence him to 30 years
that's a longer sentence than the 12 and
a half years called for
by state guidelines but less than the 40
years
chauvin could get which exceeds state
guidelines prosecutors write
as this court has already found
defendant's conduct was not just an
abuse of his position
of trust and authority but an egregious
abuse of that position
they continue his actions traumatized mr
floyd's family
the bystanders who watched mr floyd die
and the community
and his conduct shocked the nation's
conscience
i do believe that it constitutes
prosecutor prosecutorial misconduct
but chauvin's attorney eric nelson wants
probation for his client with time
served or less time than required by the
sentencing guidelines
nelson cites chovin having no criminal
history his service in the military and
the police department
nelson cites chauvin being awarded two
medals of valor
two medals of commendation and various
life-saving awards
but nelson also called chauvin the
product of a broken system
when asking for a lighter sentence
nelson writes that chauvin has the
support of his family including his
ex-wife his step-children
and her family despite their divorcing
earlier this year
until now chauvin has exercised his
right to remain
silent it's not known whether he will
speak at his sentencing
one of the things the judges take into
consideration is do you accept
responsibility for your actions and do
you show remorse
so it will be interesting to see whether
chauvin says
anything now prosecutors are able to ask
for a much longer sentence than allowed
by the guidelines because judge cahill
found that aggravating factors existed
when george floyd died including the
fact that children were
present and witnessed his death brian
thanks ange joining us today is criminal
defense attorney gigi gonzalez and terry
austin
gigi as you heard the defense is asking
for probation with time
served because sheldon has no criminal
record among other things
and also that he's a product of a broken
system what do you make of those
arguments by the defense
you know it's always the defense
attorney's first priority to make sure
they advocate for their clients and get
them the best possible sentence uh
based on the unique circumstances and
facts of each case
here you have chauvin who is found
guilty on three charges for the murder
of george floyd
um this is a murder that was committed
in front of children
in front of the entire world that cost
this city 27 million dollars
and a defense attorney has to be
reasonable when they make their requests
and sentencing
memorandums and here i'm not sure this
is reasonable for all of the reasons i
just stated
so i don't know if they're going to be
successful in earning a probation
sentence that's essentially
a misdemeanor sentence for the killing
of an innocent human being
couldn't have said it better now terry
prosecution asking for 30 years you
heard with the defense asking for far
less
if shroven does serve any jail time he's
only going to serve two-thirds of that
in jail
and a third on parole are these
reasonable requests by either side
well obviously i think that the request
by the defense as gigi said was not
reasonable
but i do think the prosecution's
recommendation for
the 30 years was reasonable although i
think he could have gone for the 40
years because
the judge did decide that these
aggravating factors four of them really
applied that he abused his authority he
was particularly cruel
he was working with a group and he did
this in front of children so
they could have gone for the entire
maximum for the highest count he was
convicted
of all three and 40 years is the highest
so i would have gone for that but
we'll see what happens i agree as i'm
reading this
so many arguments from nelson
specifically that he says shovel was
unaware he was committing a crime
and that these aggravating factors
weren't as bad as other cases
it sounds almost like nelson is arguing
a federal civil rights case and not
sentencing was there any confusion when
you read some of these arguments in the
motion
i mean i wasn't confused but i think it
could uh play into the federal case
you know in the federal case that you
know violation of a civil rights
under the law it's a willful standard
and it's been explained to me that that
means that basically they have to prove
the prosecutors that derek chauvin
knew what he was doing was wrong and
trashed the constitution
and went ahead and did it anyway and
just ignored
the constitutional rights of george
floyd so
being unaware that you were committing a
crime or doing something wrong in your
product a product of a broken system it
sounds like they're going to put the
whole police department
on trial with that case we'll see how
that plays out i would agree with you
there
looks like they're doing just that let's
check in on some top legal stories
making headlines in the law
and crime network including officers
getting quite the surprise when
responding to an accident in utah
west valley city police officers walked
onto the scene of a head-on collision
of a sedan with a semi-truck when they
opened the door
they realized the driver was a
nine-year-old girl the passenger
her four-year-old sister she's driving
the two apparently went out on a
california vacation while their parents
slept
but didn't make it very far police say
the girls drove about 10 miles on a
highway and freeway
before exiting hopping on a median and
crashing
thankfully no one was hurt both the
girls were wearing their seat belts
and in florida two teens are accused of
breaking into a home
stealing weapons and firing at deputies
the local sheriff says a 12 year old boy
and 14 year old girl
ran away from their foster home and
found another home with ak-47s
and 200 rounds of ammunition as deputies
were approaching
they say the teens opened fire the
deputies reportedly didn't fire back
until the 14 year old exited the house
and continued to fire
the girl was shot on the chest and arm
and is in stable condition
the two are facing charges of attempted
murder of law enforcement officers
and armed burglary
still ahead on law and crime daily our
own dan abrams brings you a preview
of god mom the disappearance of jennifer
doulos but first
opening statements from the trial of a
tennessee man accused of killing his
five-year-old son
why an alleged confession is now being
contested next
welcome back we're headed to tennessee
where our father's on trial
for the murder of his five-year-old
nonverbal autistic son
joseph clyde daniels who was lovingly
called baby joe
was last seen on april 3rd 2018. the
next day
his father called 9-1-1 to report his
son is missing
daniels was brought in for questioning
and confessed to murdering baby joe
and disposing of his body but he later
recanted and his attorneys now say he
was coerced baby joe's mother
crystal daniels was also charged and
will stand trial at a later date
baby joe's remains have never been found
prosecutors say the five-year-old was
beaten to death
because he urinated on the floor
claims that he wakes up at 5 30 a.m
goes into the bedroom and finds that joe
clyde is gone
he says he searches the house goes
around outside
can't find him and the search begins
at 6 22 a.m so roughly 52 minutes after
he notices
joe clyde is missing from the house he
makes a 911 you will hear the defendant
claims that joe clyde
escaped he says my son has escaped and
we cannot find him
he has autism last time he was seen was
last night how did he get out of the
house
he was asked on the 911 call and the
defendant says he must have unlocked the
door
he describes joe clyde as being roughly
48 inches tall
and 65 pounds he's asked how severe is
his autism and he says he
has adhd with it too pretty significant
he can't talk
unable to communicate he tries to bathe
himself but we have to obey them
and you're going to hear this on the 911
call
the defense team says dales gave a false
confession in their opening statement
and insist he's innocent
so they do get a confession but i submit
to you
that it was a false confession and not
just because
the agent doubted whether he was telling
truth not just because the agent said
are you making this up
that's a great indicator that even the
tbi thought he's making it up
but also because what he told them
was not borne out by the evidence
you'll see that the forensic scientists
went into the house
they cut up carpet to check for stains
around the coffee table they checked the
coffee table
they searched the house thoroughly they
searched the vehicle
the trunk of the vehicle and even though
our client had confessed
to beating this child 15 to 20 minutes
even though he said there was blood
running down
both sides of his face even though all
that was said
not one drop of joe clyde daniel's blood
was found anywhere in the house
not on the coffee table not in the
carpet
here with us again is criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and terry austin
terry i know it doesn't happen that all
that often but if the defense can
produce
everything they promise in their opening
statement could this be an acquittal or
is the case just too strong against them
i think the case is too strong against
them i doubt very seriously if there
will be an acquittal you have to have
unanimous verdict there
i think that the defense might raise
some doubt in
one juror's mind which means obviously
that will get a hung jury
but he was all over the place with his
opening statement i mean he was trying
to raise doubt saying that someone named
daniel mccormick
saw the boy wearing a t-shirt in the
middle of the road he said a woman's
child's boots were missing another young
girl saw him in muddy pajamas you know
and that the police
failed to follow leads about this sex
offender who lived in the neighborhood
so he's throwing things out there
whether or not it sticks i think is
another whole thing i
don't think there will be an acquittal
though so it sounds like the defense
strategy of throw the spaghetti against
the wall and see what sticks
jg joseph daniels is charged with murder
but not the
wife could that be because of the
confession or do you think the
prosecution has something up their
sleeve
we haven't seen yet well if they've got
something up their sleeve they better
show it
i think this confession is really what
made the
murder charge possible here because as
we heard in opening statements there's
no other forensic evidence that's going
to support
um you know a murder charge here and in
joseph daniel's confession he did not uh
place any blame on crystal
and i don't believe he you know even
mentioned her being involved
or even in the room so this uh
confession really set
up joseph daniels for this murder charge
agreed let's see what the prosecution
can produce
as they continue with their testimony
these are just the opening statements
coming up on law and crime daily blood
on a dishwasher
will shocking testimony break the robert
durst murder trial wide open
plus gone mom the jennifer doulo's story
our interview with executive producer
dan abrams
on what we can look forward to in the
upcoming movie and true crime
documentary
[Music]
we're back a new movie and documentary
about the story of missing mom
jennifer doulos is set to premiere this
saturday on lifetime
law and crime founder and executive
producer dan abrams gives us a sneak
peek into this double feature
i love fotus i want to have a family
with him
this morning mother of five jennifer
doulos was reported missing
based on the true story you need to find
her husband it shook the nation whatever
happened to jennifer
he is behind it annabeth gish
warren christie people make all sorts of
horrible assumptions
they don't know me i'm innocent gone bob
the disappearance of jennifer doulos
premieres june 5th only on lifetime
one of the things that made this
lifetime film
um so effective is that there really was
an effort
to base it all on the true story
to base it on what really happened with
photos dulos
and jennifer and so it really describes
the story but
unlike in a documentary in this story
there are you know there are actors
we're able to
imagine certain scenes where the two of
them would have been the only ones there
um and try to base it as much as
possible on
what really happened so the the two lead
actors are annabeth gish and warren
christie
playing jennifer and photos dulos and i
i think that they did a
a really effective job of trying to
channel
what we know about them using
information from talking to people who
knew them both
etc i mean fotus dulos had a bad temper
and you see that in the film and
jennifer doulos
um you know was put in a horrible
situation
she became a victim of of domestic
violence
and i think that you see that in the
acting you
feel it in the film and i think in a way
that
you probably might not be able to do in
the documentary
version of this which which we did as
well now dan you mentioned that you've
been following this case and you know
how
meticulous you were in understanding
this case were there any part of this
movie that you sat back and saw and
you're like
oh that's that's a good part can you
give us a little teaser of something
that really moved you in this movie
yeah i mean i think that some of the you
know it wasn't just the arguments
between photos dulos
and jennifer that moved me as much as it
was his apologies
to get her back i think that was
really telling in the film is
she's angry she knows she's got a
problem
and then suddenly this guy turns on the
charm to bring her back in
why do i think that's so important
because i think you see that
in a lot of dysfunctional and at times
violent relationships
that there are these horrible moments
followed by the abuser
then sort of stepping back and saying oh
i didn't mean any of it i'm so sorry
it'll never happen again
and and seeing that dynamic i think was
was really powerful
in the context of the film
gone mom premieres june 5th at 8pm
beyond the headlines the jennifer
doulo's story documentary airs
immediately afterwards
when we come back all's fair in love and
a murder trial
what robert durst defense is petitioning
for when we come back
welcome back attorneys in the robert
durst case are back to fighting it out
over testimony in the trial of the
millionaire real estate air accused of
murdering his best friend
prosecutors say robert durst shot susan
berman in the back
in december 2000. they're trying to also
prove that he killed her
because she was a witness to the still
unsolved disappearance of durha's first
wife kathy in 1982.
according to the state durst killed
kathy in their home in south salem new
york
no forensic evidence of that has been
recovered but a former housekeeper now
says
she spotted blood
there was something on the dishwasher
when you say something on the dishwasher
it's like blood i'm sorry
it looked like blood and i want to ask
you is that something
that um appeared to you to be
recent or fresh yes in the dining room
there was i didn't know there was hidden
panels
above a closet and i noticed
fingerprints on
and the panels were in these panels did
you know
previous to that that they were there
and what they were
no i did i didn't know they were there
the nypd detective in charge of the
investigation into kathy's case
says dirt told him that kathy got on a
train and headed into the city
added edited recorded testimony from the
now retired detective
was played for the jury
[Music]
for consent
[Music]
that bob durst was responsible for the
disappearance of
this why did you not justify that
after the jury was sent out the defense
objected to the prosecution's line of
questioning of the detective
something about how it's outrageously
repetitious
i don't know how many times it's gone
i'm angry right now
and i guess you can tell that by my tone
of voice but if he's
asked those questions once he's asked
him at least
15 times and i objected well it was
cross-examination he's perfectly
anything that's perfectly proper there's
nothing wrong perfectly
perfectly acceptable to repeat it that
often judge that yes
there was also a stipulation regarding
the testimony which council
signed after reviewing yeah
i'm sorry you're angry i mean this
witness is not good for the defense
thank you both for joining us and thank
you for joining us here at law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you